[Music]
injustice to develop her nether realm
has revealed the latest character in its
super hero fighting game and if you're a
fan of the TV show arrow you might just
recognize her I'm Matt and this gamespot
news update is here to save the day
Black Canary has been revealed by itn
and she appears to be a very up close
and personal fighter with a few ranged
attacks in the form of her supersonic
screaming she also has small grenades at
amid sonic waves and leave our enemies
stunned and vulnerable giving our good
amount of time to move in for a
devastating combo and it looks like she
can parry attacks to giving her the
chance to grab an enemy mid swing and
punish them with an arm bar that would
make Ronda Rousey proud more characters
are expected to be revealed in the
coming months including three we saw on
the latest cinematic trailer poison ivy
Bane and Brainiac have all made
appearances in various places such as
the injustice to website but we haven't
seen them in action just yet we'll keep
you updated as they're properly revealed
so for that and more from the world of
video games stay tuned to gamespot
you